Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. And I
just checking in on you.
How are you doing? Sorry.
It's like eight 15 in the morning. My
wife's gonna fucking kill me. I'm sorry.
It's eight 39. All right. So
on the other side, eight 30,
you don't want to take
those construction rules.
You can't hammer a nail
till 7:00 AM I can't yell.
I'm just checking in on you until
after eight 30 in the morning.
That's the deal that we have. All
right. Um, what's going on? How,
how was your, your um, your in
between Christmas and New Year's,
so you guys get the time off,
you know,
I know the kids do kids on break,
just in time to fucking run into
that chick from high school.
You always try to bag, give it a
shot, right? Everybody else did.
You have to go to work on the 26th, the
27th year, right? Then you're right back.
It's the fucking worst.
Everybody should be off.
You shouldn't even be able to
buy food this time of year.
Everything is fucking closed.
Everybody just sit down,
fucking relax, you know, take
a week for you south week,
this fucking country, man, we
got to be more like Europe.
I don't know how they do it over there
with their fucking God damn skinny jeans
is, you know, they fucking legs are
skinny as their arms over there.
And those tall people, countries,
you know the Scandinavian countries,
you know, down in the
Mediterranean, these motherfuckers,
they get like six weeks vacation a year.
It's fucking incredible.
Why don't we do that?
Huh?
President to be Donald Trump.
Okay,
you want to make this country great?
You can make this country what?
It never fucking had six weeks
of vacation every, you know,
fucking ah, that would be
Gwen. How great would that be?
Every two months you just get a week off,
right?
Then you work for seven lucky seven.
You worked for seven fucking weeks.
Then you get a week off and just sit
there and fucking chill out and start,
you know, let all the stress of
your job go fucking start over.
Everybody is off at the same time.
Cops,
pilots.
Yeah.
You know, people who watch the nuclear
fucking facilities, you just, you know,
it's not good. Nothing's going to happen.
Right. What's the Simpsons? It's you fine.
Everybody just chill.
Even a war. That's it.
Every fucking seven weeks.
Boom.
Right.
Seven weeks you try to kill
each other and then, you know,
right when it hits the eighth
week, somebody stands up
out of that trench. Yeah.
Hi.
Okay.
Oh,
I
okay.
Oh,
you just fucking chill up. This
is, this is basically the deal.
I am mom really trying to, uh,
I think I'm going to
fucking talk to somebody.
I got to fucking get my temper under
control cause I don't want to be an angry
dad. Uh, I want to break this cycle.
Um, so somebody told me
yesterday, they go, well,
why don't you try metta meditation?
And I go get the fuck out of here.
That works. And the person was like, yeah,
I do it twice a day for 20 minutes.
And uh,
like I'm gonna have the time to do
that when I have a fucking kid. Uh,
twice a day for 20 minutes.
And um,
he said like, if you just
meditate, shut your brain off,
your body just starts getting rid
of stress. And I asked him, I said,
this has made you less angry.
He said much less angry.
So I'm going to give that a shot and
I'm going to talk to somebody, you know,
I've been cleaning up all my shit,
trying to get rid of a bunch of stuff
and I found this empty notebook and I was
like, all right, this is going to be
like my fucking angry journal, you know,
figure out, oh my God.
Yesterday I got the, you know,
the amount of shit that I just,
I just completely,
I go from zero to 9,000 fucking degrees.
Um,
you know,
yesterday I pulled up and there was some
guy fucking parked in, in, you know,
the top of my driveway cause yet another
thing was fucked up with my house.
They tell you guys the awning
fucking broke. It's, it's just,
it just never fucking ends. It just
Nav this fucking house. It never rents.
I just find myself, I feel like I'm
running in a giant circle that I'm,
once I get everything fucking
fixed, you know, 360 degrees,
rotisserie fucking, uh, uh,
whatever the fuck rebuild
of this fucking house.
The second I do the last thing,
the first thing I fixed is going to break
and it's just going to start all over
again. So, um, anyways, I'm
going to try to do that.
And um,
okay.
You know,
it's fucking hilarious is like when
I actually am calm and I am relaxed,
it actually makes my wife nervous
in a way. Like not like nervous,
like she's afraid I'm going to do
something. She's just like, she's like,
are you a everything okay
with you? Uh, what's,
what's going on with you? And it's just
like nothing. I'm just quiet and relaxing.
She's this. Yeah. Are you okay?
So, um, I got to dial it way the fuck out.
You know, I think my
average energy, you know,
you ever played like pickup whatever sport
and there's always that person taking
it way too seriously.
And before the game even starts,
they skate up next to you or they
stand next post up or whatever.
You can just feel their fucking
energy and you're just like, Oh God,
not this fucking guy. I hate to
admit it, but I think I'm that guy,
except I'm not playing a sport.
I'm just fucking walking around my house.
MMM.
I Dunno what the fuck it is, but, uh,
I have to work on that shit. So, um,
as I've been mentioned, you guys have
been getting rid of a ton of shit.
MMM.
You know, selling stuff, having
a buddy of sell it on craigslist,
trying to take as little as
I can to goodwill because
I really believe that they
just fill that fucking truck up with 90%
of the shit, just throw it in the ocean.
So I'm actually trying
to sell it to people. Um,
just the sheer amount of shit that
people bring down to goodwill.
Like people use goodwill,
you know what I mean?
Without ever addressing their fucking
consumerism. And I did it too,
like how much shit I bought and just
how every time you leave the house,
she come home with something else in a
bag and then it's just in your fucking
house. Like when me and Nia first moved
in with two people in a fucking house,
I mean, it was like echo, echo, and
all of a sudden, five years later,
it's fucking filled up. I'm
like, what? What happened?
How did we become these people?
So, Ooh, ow, Ooh. So, um,
I'm, I'm getting rid of
like all of this clutter.
Uh,
you know, like I have every fucking laptop
just about that I've ever fucking had.
I've always kept them because I dunno,
like I always hear that, you know,
they end up in junk yards and something
leaks out of him. And I'm like, well,
why don't I just leave it and my fucking
closet? It's not hurting anything.
It's just sitting there and then I
got to win there. Then I got three,
then I got four.
So I'm going to try to find a place
that recycles them responsibly.
Um, so anyways, throughout
all of this, people go,
you gotta check out this documentary,
these guys, the minimalists.
And um,
I started to watch it the other night and,
uh, I'm totally on board. It's what
I want. And I'm watching it with the,
and it's fucking hilarious is I can
feel her getting annoyed and I'm like,
yeah, you're watching this and shit. She
goes, yes. She goes, you know, I don't,
you know,
I liked my stuff.
Blahblahblahblahblah and I kept
poking at it to see what the deal was.
And she's finally just like,
yeah,
I just don't give a shit about a bunch
of white people that are all excited that
they're now living with like absolutely
nothing. You know, they, they, you know,
if they fucking, how the fuck
did she put it? She goes,
there's a lot of people live in like
that not out of there wasn't a choice.
Right. And I was like, Oh, Jesus Christ,
we're going to go down that fucking road.
We actually had a great conversation.
I was like, you know what,
there's a certain kind of white person
that have fucking annoys the shit out of
you. She goes, no, there
is like a, yeah, there is.
It's still white person that is not
happy in life and is trying to, to,
to figure out what true
happiness is because the
stereotype of a white person is
that they just show up in all
their dreams come true. All right.
These are just a group of people
that were living away certain way.
It wasn't making them happy.
They tried something new,
it made them happy and they
just want to share it with you.
And this is why my wife's a
shit. She goes, hi, now that
you put it that way, okay,
fair enough. I was being judgmental,
blah blah blah, blah. We came,
we came to a good place, but
it was fucking, she went,
I wish you guys could have heard it.
She went on one of her fucking epic rants.
I was dying laughing because I,
I heard the element of truth in it,
but um, I dunno know there is
all of that shit out there.
Is that that fucking thing,
how every group of people is like defined,
you know,
by a negative and a,
yeah.
You know, I guess with white
people is that, you know,
we have yachts and were raised by
the maid who's not white and uh,
whatever we want we get and then we screw
it up and then our parents come in and
save us cause they know the judge,
you know, and that's definitely,
that's an option as a white
person, but that's, you know,
you've really slicing off
the top of the ham there
anyways. Um, so,
okay,
this is going to be the new me,
you know, let's see how long,
who the fuck's kid and who, let's
see a long, I can sustain this. Okay.
Because the reality is is
you are who the fuck you are.
And I am a wound up son of a bitch and um,
I'm going to try to unwind as much as
I can for as long as I can before I go
back into that deep groove that I've
worn into how my brain is functioned.
Uh, I'm going to try to fucking
meditate. I'm going to get, yeah.
Rid of all of this fucking shit.
Then I have accumulated,
mmm.
You know,
for years already I've gone to like
comedy events and stuff and they're always
giving you this gift bag.
It's, and it's Shit Shit.
It just, you know, I don't know
what the fuck I have to shit.
I don't even know what the fuck it is.
Little things at Jelly beans with
the fucking festivals name on it,
some toiletries, some
travel bag shit, you know,
all in a little bag that has the logo,
the thing on it. And you're like,
I gotta keep this, you know, part of
my scrapbook that I don't fucking have.
And I just, when I started to
do as I just say no, I say no.
And then if it gets weird and
they had this vibe of like, Hey,
I'm trying to give you a gift
here and you're turning it down.
I kind of feel insulted me a little bit.
Kind of insulted me a little bit here.
I will take the bag and then when I
do is I come home and then I just,
I give it to somebody. Hey, no, I
just said to stay a techie show.
You don't want it. Yeah. Take it,
take it, get it the fuck outta here.
You know what's funny too is actually
now when you go out and you try and sell
your shit, you realize how little fucking
value it has. You know what I mean?
Um,
I dunno.
And I should tell you when as they
sell the shit have an element of guilt.
And I always think of that movie.
What about Bob?
When that therapist past
Bob onto Richard Dreyfus,
that's what I feel like I'm doing with
my stuff is I'm selling to these people.
I'm just looking at him and say by it.
I'm like,
you're not going to fucking use that
your problem now buddy.
Um, so anyways, that's what I've
been, that's what I'm doing.
I got to a,
I have to chill way the fuck out.
Um,
for the next 18 to 22 years have a deadly.
And so I imagine I'll get some tweets.
Don't you think that's going to
hurt your comedy? No, I don't.
I've been fucking up my life
for almost half a century.
I have plenty to draw on.
And just the fact of someone being his
wound up as me trying to walk around and
act like,
you know,
wearing a sweater and laughing at small
talk is going to do it for me. Right,
right. There there'll be
something in that. Right.
Well maybe you weren't thinking that.
Maybe that's what I'm worried about and
I'm saying that you're saying it so I
don't look like I'm, um, I'm fucking
weak on some level. Um, so anyways.
All right. Jesus Christ's, I've just
been fucking babbling like some chicken,
one of these fucking shows.
But bill,
maybe you got a little fucking reality
chicken. You, you have to think ahead.
Was fucking God. Damn cough ever go away.
I'm sorry. Let's do that again. You know,
I find it really irritating that I,
uh,
took some medication for
a cough a long time ago,
about a month ago and I haven't,
I'm not smoking cigars.
I am getting a good
night's sleep and I just,
for some reason in order
to do this is my wife, uh,
is so pregnant right now that
she doesn't remotely get cold.
So the fucking heat has
been off in the house.
All the ag, I walk around with like a
sweatshirt on. I just look at, I go,
you're not cold at all.
Like my feet are fucking free.
Like we literally in the house, it's
like a log cabin. There's like no,
okay,
no heat on whatsoever.
You be here.
It now I've got to run the background
cause she's fucking upstairs. Right. Um,
but like,
you know,
I got this old house and they got these
cool fucking old windows and I don't
want to get rid of them because they
don't make them like that anymore.
But the wind just fucking passes through.
Yeah.
Oh, the wind just goes right through
my fucking house. I swear to Christ.
It's unbelievable.
Only thing missing is just like leaves
just blowing by when I'm in the fucking
living room. So I'm always
cranking up the fucking heat.
She starts looking like she's under
like 20 blankets. So I have to,
she know what the deal is as a guy,
you're going to fucking
lose your fucking loose.
Why do I keep trying to
turn on my computer? Like,
like I actually have internet
connections down here. Um, all right.
It's getting to the point where
I got to read some of these, uh,
some of these fucking reads here.
We've got a doctor's
appointment with my wife today.
Stupid fucking things you got to go
to was a guy and when he to be there,
no one's going to fucking,
no one's going to talk to you at all.
But uh,
you know,
we still need you to be here cause
I haven't been to like the last two.
They weren't important ones.
You know,
they're just sort of check up things
and like she, she used to go on.
Everybody's saying, where's your
husband? Where's your husband?
We miss not talking to him when he's here.
All right, let's do some
reads here. Wink, wink.
W I N C as in Kentucky.
Finding great new wine is tough.
That's why I've been telling you all about
our sponsor, Columbia vehicle of Dell.
You're looking for weapons
of mass destruction and
how they make it so easy to
get wine personalized to your palate
and delivered right to your door.
And here's a little update for you
club Debbie. Her daddy loved me.
Best is now called Winc, spelled
w, I, n. C as in country,
a new name, then an improved looked.
But here's the important thing.
It's still the same amazing wine
company introducing you to new wines.
You'll love wink.
Winz is in cock,
works directly with wine makers and
growers from all over the world to create
delicious wine to deliver it right
to your door. You're fucking drunk.
Winks 100% satisfaction guarantee means
if you don't like a bottle they send you,
they'll replace it with a bottle.
You'll love no questions asked. Well,
there you go. You cheap fox, suck
the thing down and be like, hey,
didn't really like it. Then you get
another one that's the old too for you.
Just don't, uh, you don't
just get random bottles, wink,
wy and C as in Casa is personalized
wine membership that reminds wine that
recommends wine specifically for you based
on the results of your palate profile
quiz. There's some big brother's
shit you can also wrote.
You can also rate all of the
wine you receive from wink.
So they'll learn about you with every
order and constantly personalize wine they
send. Sign up for Winc right now. Win.
See a clitoris right now and gain
immediate insult. Childish Bill.
Why do you keep doing?
You know what?
Cause it's funny and it's
making you listen to the
whole fucking head, isn't it?
Immediate insiders to gain immediate
insider access to the best fine wine from
all around the world. Fuck, oh my
God, this the infidels. Delicious.
Find out for yourself why yours truly
and thousands of other satisfied wine
lovers are raving about Winc. I'm
not ready. I'm reading the copy.
I don't drink wine. It gives me a brutal
fucking hangover. The best part I,
you know what? If I have
a nice meal, you know,
and I something from fucking Blue Apron,
maybe I'll have a glass of wine right of
Nia has one of her fucking friends over
and everybody's sitting around.
They got the fire going. You know,
you always feel like you're in the big
chill when your wife has friends over.
The best part, wink is over, is
offering my listeners $20 off right now.
When you go to try winc.com/burr
they'll even cover the shipping.
Think about it.
Are you done thinking you'll get fine
wine personalized to your palate?
We get it delivered right to your fucking
door. You just said this shit. Try Winc.
W I n C as in cynical.
It's funny spells cynical, is it?
Isn't it with an s o s and c one?
Are you guys going to just
fucking combined, you know like,
like one of those Dunkin donuts pizza
hut things a try Winc and get $20 off
complimentary shipping
right now when you try,
when you go to try winc.com/bird that's
w I n C as in cat.com/ [inaudible] oh
blue apron. Everybody. You know,
not all ingredients are created equal.
Oh Jesus.
It's just like the Klu Klux clans
fucking food thing. Fresh, high quality.
What ingredients? They didn't
say that make a real difference.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Why to fucking really race
people say Hawaii white people.
H w. I. T. E,
a genuine quiet gold.
Talk about your personal experience.
Fuck you. Affordable for less
than $10 per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes.
Would you like some pumpkin pie with pre
portioned ingredients to make delicious
home cooked meals?
The variety to choose from a variety of
new recipes each week or let blue apron
culinary team surprise you.
Recipes are not repeated within a year,
so you never gonna to get bored.
Flexible.
Customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you could choose what fits your needs
and there's no weekly commitment,
so you only get this one
so you only get deliveries
when you want them.
I'm going to do how they
sing in my church. Easy.
Each meal comes with step by step,
easy follow recipe card,
pre portioned ingredients and
prepared in 40 minutes or less.
Guarantee blueway prince freshness.
Guarantee promises that every ingredient
in your delivery already ready to cook
all they'll make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/bre.
You'll love how good it feels and tastes
to create incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron. So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook. That's a great
way to get in shape too. You know,
easy to cook meals.
You come home,
you fucking put it together before
you do something dumb, you know,
like order a pizza and then
I have some ice cream, right?
And then spoon with a fat guy, you know,
and his fatness just fucking, you know,
you ever done the ever spoon with
the fat guy just makes you fatter.
That's a true story. Um, all right,
where the fuck am I in this podcast?
20 fucking minutes.
And you know something,
some days it doesn't feel like
work and other days it does.
This is one of these days.
Um,
when you think Obama's thinking right now,
I always think like this time of year,
this time, like when a president is in
their second term, it's fucking December.
Okay,
you've got another couple of weeks before
the next fucking poor bastard comes in
there. You know, and I do meet bastard
cause it's always going to be a,
but it's always going to be a guide.
Ladies always going to be a guy.
All right?
That job is for a man.
There's certain things that men can't
do and there's certain things that women
can do and women can do a bunch of things.
But running the country is,
is just not one of those things.
I mean people are gonna just going to
take that clip and take all the fucking,
you know, I'm just fucking
around of it. Out of there. Yeah.
It's these thing that women say,
Hey, what do you call it?
Those Youtube fucking stars,
those fucking cunts you don't like when
like that guy punched the kangaroo in
the face and you want to see it and you
go to click on it and then this is just
this fucking high energy,
20 something Douche with the
Janet Jackson fucking microphone.
Can I take your order please? Going, okay.
See this caring.
Okay.
We're all familiar with the kangaroo
and then they cut to some shit about
Kangaroos and they just take this
fucking, this fucking clip. It's,
it's like, it's like, dude,
I don't fucking need you. I
know what's going to happen.
Just show me the original clip and these
fucking cunts insert themselves into it.
And then they,
they're making like 250 grand at God
damn fucking video assumption. You know,
they like the DJ's of
youtube in a waybill Doo,
Doo, Doo Doo Doo to do till, till to the
same fucking thing. They're doing that.
They're fucking remix in this
shit that taken other people's to,
I don't even know what deejaying
is. I have no fucking idea. Yeah.
I don't even know why I make fun of it.
Boy.
Yeah you do belly cause you got to
fucking a half hour to fill up here. Um,
anyway, so did I mention I was, I've
been trying to do the impossible.
I can't remember if I
already talked about this.
I'm trying to watch like every Bruin
game and every self that came this year
cause you got to choose you either a
basketball guy or a hockey guy and I've
been trying to watch the other night
I watched a Bruins game and then uh,
well then a fucking Celtic game.
I watched the uh,
I don't know if I already talked about
this cause I fucked up the podcast and
had to start it again.
I don't give a shit.
I watched the Bruins lose four to three
to the blue jackets and then I watched
the Celtics after that
beat the Memphis Grizzlies.
I believe I already talked about this.
I have no idea.
All I know is the fucking
NFL playoffs are coming up.
Does anything repeat anything go by faster
then the fucking
NFL regular season,
you know it goes by faster.
My fucking train of thought.
I was talking about
presidents this time of year.
You know how fucking site that would
be after eight fucking years of being
president. The stress of that,
the fucking stress of that.
All the bodies, all the people that died
because of the decisions that you made.
It's fucking inevitable.
Okay. Cause you answer,
you answered to the, the, the
reptilian people at the top.
You know,
and I don't mean shape shifters,
I just mean people who do not give a
fuck about anything but themselves and
their money and power. That's all they
care about. They don't care who suffers.
They don't give a shit.
They don't believe in God.
They believe that their a god or
they believed that God is fucking,
you know,
bestowed them with this great
responsibility to run the fucking world.
I tried to take over it or whatever.
Right. I always just think like,
as much as Obama doesn't
want to see Trump,
he has to be so fucking site.
You know,
like if I was Obama right now,
I would just be like, dude,
I'm getting all the
fucking sports packages.
I'll get myself a pair of silk
fucking pajamas, you know,
with sheepskin fucking slippers
and I'm not doing shit I am not going
to do. But they have to do shit.
You know why? Because the president
only makes 500 grand a fucking year.
So now what he has to do is now
for the rest of his fucking life,
he has to go out and give these
speeches. Okay. Which is, you know,
to the people that put them in office,
they pay him like six fucking figures
to get out there and tell his fucking
jokes into his little song and dance.
And the reality is,
is that just washing their
fucking bribe money, you know,
so he would push through all the shit
that they wanted or as much of it as they
could while he was in office. And
then they also get to see like, yeah,
see we own this guy.
You know,
is it bringing new lizards into their
fucking dent to be like, see this,
we actually have former presidents come
here and do a little song and dance for
us. You know why? Because
we own this fucking guy.
We owned them before even fucking went
in there. We own the fucking next guy.
You know, that's probably why, you know,
as much as the upper 1% probably did not
want to see Donald Trump get in there
because he's this fucking row guy and all
you fucking progressive lefties, he's,
oh, they got it. They
shut the fuck up. Uh,
they're actually gonna end up loving that
guy because it seems what he wants to
do is deregulate everything because
guys at his level of wealth,
this so fucking rich,
they find the government annoying.
I have to answer to Ho who is it that
the u s government,
I these fucking assholes. They
opened the door. What, what,
what now? Well, you
know, just uh, you know,
kind of appreciative for I where the
u s government talks to that level of
wealth because they need them to get
it to fucking office. Right. You know,
kind of appreciated if,
you know,
you wouldn't build that golf course over
that homeless shelter and those native
Americans, you know, you know, I
don't know. I'll think about it.
I'll think about it. All right.
Just fucking go fuck yourself.
I do what I want
are making money off opiates.
Shut the fuck up. I don't know. I Dunno.
I Dunno what to take,
but you know what?
I'm in fucking limbo right
now is where I am. Um,
I haven't been doing stand up. I can't
go out. I can't really leave the house.
I'm afraid to fucking leave
the house because you know, I,
I stay within like a
certain fucking radius.
So if my wife does not have our kid,
uh,
by January 2nd,
I am going to the rose bowl and I am
going to do the unspeakable at there.
I am going to be sober as a church mouse.
I won't even smoke a cigar because I have
to let those fucking things go because
I have to get life insurance and uh,
I don't want to pay the,
I'm a smoker and I don't want to
be a smoker. I, you know what,
I'll fucking smoke like for a year.
That's what I think.
Oh well I enjoy the fucking shit
out of those. Uh, yeah, dude,
I'm getting to that point in my life. I'm
getting my affairs in order. You know,
it's actually,
it's like,
you know what I've actually found going
through the whole process of getting
life insurance and putting together a
trust and a will and all of that Shit,
I've actually found that to be just as
enjoyable is getting rid of all this shit
in my life. All the clutter. It's the
same thing. Like this, you know, is a guy,
I think there's something like how we
just don't deal with our mortality and uh,
so you don't want to think about it,
but I got to tell you once you just
like you thinking like, yeah, okay,
and something happens to me. You get this,
you get debt. And I'm fucking out, right.
And nobody is, you know, nobody
has to worry about anything.
And then they call and be like,
you know what, that son of a bitch,
I don't know what he was doing as
swimming with those sharks, but uh,
I've got to tell you, he'd say one
thing about that guy, you know,
he had his affairs in order.
You gotta be that guy.
If you have any sort of wife,
children, anything, you got it.
You got to get your fucking
affairs in order. And um,
I haven't done it like a lot of my
friends didn't and none of them had their
affairs in order and a
number of them died. And uh,
that is just a fucking thing.
I'm telling you right now.
You do not want to put your
fucking family through that.
And I'm not going to be that guy.
So hopefully I won't die before. Uh,
I get everything all fucking
straightened out here. But that is my,
that's my first thing I'm
going to do in the, in 17.
I'm going to prepare my affairs.
My affairs will be in order. Oh
God, this can be so weird. You know,
so weird about getting life insurance
as you then give your partner motive,
you know?
Yeah.
My wife doesn't have
fucking life insurance. She
doesn't even think about it.
They don't give a fuck about
us. Right. And you know what?
I don't want her to have life insurance
get off because then I got to deal with
the cops. If something came out. Well,
didn't you make fucking six figures when
she fell down that flight of stairs?
I swear to God,
I was by myself.
I was playing drums in a rehearsal space.
You know,
I spent so much time alone every day
that I would never have a fucking alibi.
God forbid if something ever
happened. Can Anybody, uh,
can anybody vouch for you
that that's where you were at?
And then I would have to go into my head.
Who did I yell at on the way?
There are the way back in a fucking car.
Did I get their license plate
so I can call them up and say,
do you remember that bald red
bearded asshole who screamed at you?
You know? Yeah. That you
remember that you, can you,
do you remember what time of day that was?
This is really critical for me.
Um, yeah, it's, it's a very
bizarre thing to go out and uh,
it's, it's, it's uh, makes you feel
at peace and then also, you know,
it makes you, you know, when your wife,
you know, brings over you like some food,
you kind of looking at her,
then you're looking at the
food, you know, she gets up,
you switch plates.
I think I've watched too many of
those first 48, you know what I mean?
I love those guys the way they fucking
their first two wives die mysteriously
and then someone else fucking Mary's.
It's just like,
this is the fucking thing. You can
marry somebody who had one person die.
Okay. That happens. Unfortunately
that fucking happened.
But once they're there, they're at to
get the fuck away from that person.
But what are the, what are the fucking
odds, you know, you got married in both.
Your husbands died, he married twice.
I'm a, I'm a two time widower. We have,
well you're not going to be a three time
the fuck away from me. Check please.
Right. He was that Hacky fucking out
to every comedy scene. I'll just,
I'll have what she's having. Um, yeah,
you gotta get the fuck out of there.
You know you can only have one spouse die.
Okay.
In after that,
if I was running shit,
if I was one of the Lizard people and I
was running shit, this would be the rule.
Anybody who had two
spouses die and you know,
we can't prove that you fucking did it.
You are only allowed to
date other people that had,
that are already had two people
die. Okay. And then, you know,
yeah,
whoever dies in that who gives a shit
cause then you just got rid of one murder
and psycho and then you just keep having
them date each other and eventually
then there's only one and then you
stick that person in a giant like human,
like parakeet cage and like this Gary,
it's, there's the winter or this.
She is right.
Okay.
All 48 of her husband's died
mysteriously can never prove it.
You know,
take it down and put it on Coney island.
Does that still exist?
That fucking rollercoaster.
You ever go to Coney island goal and
that one, that fucking rollercoaster.
It's one of the scariest fucking rides
I've ever been on. Not because it's,
it's like a scary ride.
It's because the ride is so fucking old
and there's no padding in this seat.
I swear to God,
I got off that ride.
I felt like I was in a
fucking three car accident.
Yeah.
You know, my fucking back was killing
me. My shoulder was fucked up.
MMM.
I don't know.
You don't.
I'm probably fucking up my life right now
cause I'm trying to do too many things
at once as I always do. I'm going
to meditate. I'm going to do yoga.
I'm going to fucking eh, stop yelling.
I'm gonna. I'm gonna go to therapy and Ba,
ba Ba ba Ba. I think I'm freaking
out because I'm a fucking,
a volatile fucking lunatic
and I th I don't want a,
I don't want to be that person,
you know? You know, we want to be,
I want to be like fucking Joe
Pesci in casino, you know,
minus watching my brother getting
beat to death in a cornfield.
Like not that part. The part where he's
making pancakes for his kid, you know,
despite the fact he squeezed somebody's
eyeball out in a vice like 20 minutes
earlier, then he could come
home, he could shut it off.
It's very inspirational and he wants more
syrup. I, you know, I love you. Right.
Kisses him on the head, you know,
and that's it. Then he goes out,
he fucking kneecap somebody's,
you know,
20 seconds after the bus drives away
with his kid. That's who I want to be.
All right, man. That's it.
That's the podcast. Uh,
and I got to admit, you know,
it's been hard for me to watch a
okay,
the Bruins this year, man. So I've
actually been watching more NBA hoop,
which I'm really fucking embarrassed to
say because I've always been a hockey
guy, but you know, I will always
be Aki. Got. But I, it's also,
I can't ignore watching what Danny
Ainge is doing. It's fucking great.
It's so much fun to watch. Um, so
you know what? Let's look up here.
Who Do we got next? I don't know who the
Celtics half next, but you guys here.
Aaron Kaufman is leaving fucking
gas monkey fast. Fast and loud.
It's fucking brutal.
Okay.
But the way our discovery talked about it,
it sounded like he was going to get
his own show, but it's just like,
what the fuck? I don't want to see
that. I want to see this spinoff,
you know?
Well, the Vernon surely were on
happy days. That was one of the,
one of the best times ever. Then they
got their own show wasn't as good.
It's like when a super group breaks up
and then the lead singer does their thing
and then the other bag gets a new sense,
like Van Halen,
David Lee Roth was never better
than when he was in Van Halen.
Van Halen was never better than
when David Lee Roth was there.
You know what I mean? Sammy Hagar
was better when he was by himself.
What are you talking about, Bill? I don't
know. Just fucking talking. Oh, you know,
I'm just listening. All right
bro. It's what do we got next?
Da Da da Da. That the toto
to Ah, we got a home and all,
I'm against the fucking buffalo sabers.
I'd never understood that home at home.
It's a home in a way.
Who's his fucking Hitler youth
that they got number 55 on defense.
We're still Lania. We're
still laden. Jesus Christ.
Tell me his grandfather doesn't
live down in fucking South America.
Oh, that's an old Nazi fucking
hundred joke. All right,
we're going to end on that.
That's the podcast for this week.
Uh, um, just checking in on you.
That's all the fuck it was. And
if you guys want to, uh, you know,
keep listening to here.
We're going to play a little fucking
music and you're going to listen to some,
uh, some greatest hits from a podcast
gone by in a time. I can't remember.
All right. Have a great weekend. You
constant. I'll talk to you on Monday.
Alright.
Oh,
new years everybody. Here
we go. Dear Billy Ball drop.
Okay.
I'm not going to ask you what you're
doing on New Year's cause I already know
you and your Rosebowl crew will be tap
dancing at the Wilton over there. Uh,
I'm going to be there with
the girl. I'm 50% into. Okay,
well then that affects, uh,
what you should be buying
her that night. And he goes,
she's cool, she's hot and I don't
have any major complaints about her.
I'm also not in love with her and really
can't see anything beyond hooking up.
My plan is to laugh my ass off and see
what happens. All right, if we hook up,
that's great. If not, no big deal, dude.
You're in the zone. You're in the zone.
This is some demand shit. You don't
care if she comes, stays laser praise.
Now you've got the head dude. Um, I don't,
I told two friends and they boast,
advised against talking up with her.
All right, well I don't know your friends
and I don't know what their motive is.
Let's see if you explain this.
Here he goes,
I would never let that decide
whether or not I would.
But the interesting thing is that they
both said independent of each other,
that hooking with a girl
on New Year's Eve, Mike,
give her the wrong impression and that
she's going to be a leach afterwards.
Oh that's fucking, that's just
fear mongering. That's bullshit.
What? Cause your finger
Rah Rah. As the ball drops,
all of a sudden you have a relationship.
They had a good time. Had some laughs.
So like you don't want to go to
the farmer's market. No I don't.
Do you have something against
farmers markets? Not really clear.
Why don't you let it go?
Cause you know I,
I don't feel like going with you. I don't
feel like a spark your fucking ass off.
For what being honest. I
have. Fuck you there. It's,
it's the end of the
relationship. Anyway, so he goes,
I can't even fathom why New Year's Eve
would be be considered a special occasion
that would lead to her thinking that this
whole topic is ridiculous and I can't
even stand to waste time talking about it.
But I wanted to hear your opinion.
I think I just gave it to you. My
question to you is do you agree with that?
And also,
do you think there are any days on the
calendar that would make a girl think you
were into her? Oh yeah. If you
took around on Valentine's Day.
Yeah, it's about it. Valentine's Day,
Valentine's Day that that would be it.
What else?
What other day Saint Patrick's Day,
you know,
you sitting there eating a
fucking meat pie next door,
hammered Audi of mine with a green plastic
hat on. I think he really likes me.
Um,
the key and if I could,
if I could do my single life
over again is I would have been
okay
way less fearful to be honest.
You know,
when relationships were starting,
you know,
uh,
women are not as,
yeah,
psycho is, you think, I mean a lot of
times when you say that women are psycho,
it's because you were
being deceptive and a yeah.
Then they go fucking psycho.
Yeah, they definitely do.
But you a lot of times creative if you
just tell them straight up front when
they're like, so what is
this? And just be like, look,
I'm not looking to get in a
relationship right now, or like, listen,
I enjoy your company,
but I'm not feeling like this spark.
Like there's something to that next level.
I just feel like you should know that
and you'll be surprised at how well they
take that. You know, they,
it's not that always, you know,
if you say that the second you feel it,
it's usually pretty early on.
So there's no really deep feelings and
that's all people just don't want to get
hurt. Okay. Believe me, I heard a lot
of fucking people believe me. And, um,
so that's what I learned.
I remember one, um,
Jesus Christ years ago
and I was just a lad living in New York.
Okay.
I remember I hooked up with this, this
woman, and she was just, you know,
so what is this? Where's this going? And
I was just like, uh, nowhere. I'm like,
fucking I 35, she was 23. I'm like,
I'm like 12 years older than you,
you know, by the time you turned 30,
I'm going to be like 60.
What do you think it's going?
She actually laughed and I was
just like, you know, she goes,
so what are we doing? But
just hanging out, having fun.
So whatever crazy thing you want to try,
but you don't want to do it with
your husband, do it with make
and that was it. And she was
just like, all right, cool.
We had fun for a few weeks and then that
was fucking it. And nobody got hurt.
And uh, you know, I lost touch with
her and that was it. No harm, no foul.
Had a great fucking time. So
there's no like, but if you look,
you take them out on Valentine's Day
and you get them a rose and all of that
shit, you start leading them on. So what
you're really talking to, I feel he's,
you're talking to two younger guys like
me probably at that like meet like how I
was, I mean, how am I trying to say this?
You're talking to two guys who
had their age right now. I,
their skill level was
what my skill level was,
what they don't know how to set it
up. So this sitting there going, oh,
don't do this. Don't bring
them out on this day. Cause
that makes them think this.
Um,
all that says to me is that they don't
know how to communicate what's going on.
So they feel like they,
and they're also in that thing where
they feel like they have to fucking throw
their jacket over a mud puddle and let
them walk on it in order to get fucked
that night.
Which you don't,
you just have to be honest
because women enjoy sex too.
And they also enjoy you telling them
what the fucking deal is. All right,
so there you go. So you don't
have anything to worry about it.
Hey, what's going on? It is,
and this is the Monday
morning podcast. Um, welcome.
Welcome. If you're new to it. I do
one of these every single Monday.
I answer questions.
People email me questions that
people send me in there. A
underrated, overrated lists,
things that they feel are underrated,
things that they feel are overrated and,
uh, New Year's resolutions. That's
what we're doing this week, Huh?
That's what we're doing.
This is like the sixth time I've
tried to start doing this podcast.
I don't know what the fuck's going on
with me this week. It's 10 in the morning.
I think I started too early. I, I
don't know why I started so early.
I have the ability to hang up at
this point and I could just erase it,
but for some reason I'm just
plowing through on this one.
Holy Shit. This had a dog fight. I
think two dogs and fighting. He hit
that shit.
The fuck is with that dog.
The owner doesn't do shit about it.
Let's see what this dog looks like.
Let's describe both people as
they come up to street. Okay.
That's kind of a fat person.
Honest people who wears that,
that you know those hats, like it looks
like you're going to be playing tennis,
but you're not.
She hasn't one of those hats and she's
got one of those little fucking terriers,
miserable fucking dog and they're
getting into some sort of a,
a little Volkswagen Gulf.
Wow.
That's a picture for
you, Huh? What are the,
what the fuck did those
dreams go off the rails?
I hate dogs, man. I love him,
but I fucking hate him. I,
I've been talking about how I'm going to
get a bulldog and now I don't know if I
can do it. I think just
as a man, you just,
they just look awesome.
And then I'm watching youtube clips
of him and that they're just a genetic
fucking mess. They, I,
I'm watching these youtube
videos, the dog snoring, it's, I,
I can't deal with that.
That'd be like, you know,
my dad used to snore like
that and I wanted to kill him.
You're trying to watch the game and he
would like fall asleep and just start
snoring. And I literally would think
about taking off one of my, you know,
the eighties back when tube socks and
we're a lot longer. And I was like,
I could choke them with this, you
know, and, uh, that's my own dad.
Can I have a fucking dog with sleep apnea?
You know,
bulldogs when they sleep,
they sound like they used to
play offensive line in the NFL.
You know what I mean?
You have is
they got to sleep upright in a chair.
That's not a fucking dog. It's like a,
it's just a blob. You
know, I got like 18 stairs.
You've got to climb up into my apartment.
Things are going to have a fucking heart
attack. And then what do I gotta do?
I gotta give him doggy fucking CPR.
Jesus Christ.
I just loved the face.
Is there a fucking dog out there that
has that bulldog face debt can breathe
but can actually exist in an apartment?
I really liked boxers,
but they're just too big. I mean, why
don't just live with a pony at that?
Oh God, what a fucking week I
had, man. What a fucking week.
I had just stayed home for the holidays.
I had the best and the best time
it was calling everybody up,
wishing everybody merry Christmas.
I was in the best fucking
mood because I was home.
You know, I didn't have to fly anywhere.
And I'm telling you people out there,
don't let your parents guilt you any more
into the fact that you have to go home
for the holidays. You
don't, you don't visit them.
Visit them during different times of the
year when the whole world is in flying
back to the east coast or out to fucking
Wisconsin or wherever the fuck you
going.
I'm telling you,
you don't have to put yourself through
it and then he can just sit there and
watch the news and you see those people
sleeping on the airport floor and you
can just laugh your ass off just knowing
that that could have been you and now
it isn't. And now someone
else is you and it's not you.
And you can laugh at you while not
feeling the pain. That makes sense.
I hope it did.
I'll tell you what doesn't make sense
as a fucking New England patriots or 11
and five and the San Diego
chargers are eight and eight,
that fucking eight games better than the
lions and they are in the playoffs. Oh,
that's sad. Sack fucking organization.
They just can't buy a break. You know,
even though they, they killed the
Broncos and then at the end of the game,
Damion Thomas and still
fucking injures himself.
You know, I dunno. I Dunno
where I'm at with the charges.
I hated them a few years ago when they
blew that game and then they started
calling the patriots a
classless organization. You
know what I mean? It's like, oh,
really? You guys with your
fucking convicted steroid user?
Who does is taunting dance
the entire fucking game.
Then he get mad because our players
taunt him back and Jesus Christ,
he is just fucking babies,
you know,
and you fucking that poor excuse
for a football stadium. You have a,
that leftover concrete from the
highway that they molded into a stadium
back when Jimmy Carter was in office,
he just fucking annoying me.
They annoy me and uh, I don't know. Okay.
This is my big sleeper pick for
the, uh, for the NFL. I think, uh,
the Carolina Panthers are
going to surprise people.
I like Jake Delona member,
how that guy played in the Superbowl years
ago and gets the Patriots and I think
they got enough. I think they got
enough to go deep into the playoffs.
And, um, I dunno about the
giants. Giants look great,
but it's just so hard to repeat.
Um,
I dunno how you guys doing
in Dallas, Huh? Jesus Christ.
That was a raping. That really was no
lube either. That was just fucking,
I was, I was brutal and it was really
brutal. I Dunno, I dunno about that.
Tony Romo. Um, anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
You want to hear something?
I'm actually in a great mood
despite the fact that this happened,
I went to pink's hot dogs.
Now for those of you who don't live in
Los Angeles and he never been to Los
Angeles, they got this fucking, ah,
they got this hot dog stand, okay.
That evidently has the greatest hot dogs
that you'll ever taste in your life.
But every time you drive by there,
there's literally, I mean, I'm not joking.
There's like 80 people in line.
I went there when I first came out here
the first week and I literally stood in
line for like an hour for a hot dog. So
I was like, well that was fucking stupid.
I'm never doing that again.
And Lo and behold,
for some reason I went to go pick up my
lovely girlfriend from work and someone
at work had mentioned to
her about pink's hot dogs.
So she got a craving and she was like,
oh my God,
can you take me of pigs?
Hot Dog? I don't know.
Somebody mentioned I did for him.
You know when girls get like that and
it would just look adorable and they
deliberately act like they're
like a little kid and you just,
you just can't fucking resist it.
So I'm like, all right sweetie,
I'll take you over to get you a hot dog.
We pull up in the line is like two and
a half times longer than it usually is.
It's literally wrapped all the way around
this fucking tin shack, by the way.
It's a 10 check.
All right?
It's on the brand and Melrose and I'm
giving you guys some great advice.
Don't ever fucking go there. All right?
So I'm like, you know, I just laugh.
I'm like, this is ridiculous.
I'm bill. I'm like, you know
what? It's the holidays.
I didn't fly.
I'm not sitting in an airport.
I'll stand in this fucking
line just to continue to,
to the tradition of me standing in fucking
lines that I really don't need to be
standing in around Christmas.
So I stand in this fucking line,
and this is the funny part.
We get their right standing in line and
as these four Asian dudes in front of me
and was standing there for 15 minutes,
the line may be moved like six feet.
So finally one of the
agents, dudes, you know,
mumble something and Cantonese or
whatever the hell he was talking and he
fucking walks up to the front of
line and he comes back. And you know,
I don't know if you know this about me,
but I'm not bilingual.
And I certainly don't speak Chinese,
but I know what this kid said in his honk,
honk at Chapin Hall fucking language. He
just said, dude, you gotta be shitting me.
Fuck this. This is just hot dogs. It's
not worth it. That's what he said.
What the Alcantara coupon and
his language and I, I, you know,
I told them and they, all, the
other three Asian dudes laughed,
looked at each other,
nodded and made the smart move.
They got the fuck out of the line.
They got out of the line and
my dumb ass was like, oh great.
I get to move up another
half foot stupid bay, right?
I stand in line for
like another half hour.
We're freezing our ass off to the point.
My girl has to go to the car.
She gets to the car and somebody writing
us $145 ticket because evidently it
became a toso after four o'clock
so she starts freaking out,
got the car. She's like, forget it,
forget it. We'll just leave.
And at this point I'm stubborn.
I'm like, no, fuck that.
I got $145 tickets,
got damn,
and I'm at least going to get
a fucking hot dog out of this.
So I had to pull the car into the lot.
I stand there for like another hour,
an hour and a half.
I'm finally turning the corner to get
to the front of the Tin Shack for a
fucking hot dog. I can't feel my
toes. I'm jumping up and down.
I'm doing a little ballistic
fucking movement here,
trying to keep the blood
in the extremities of my
body for fucking hot dog.
I'm already down 145 bucks,
but I'm going to see this thing through.
And just when I thought
it couldn't get any worse,
we were right at the corner of
[inaudible], Bria and Melrose.
So at every red light people are just
staring at us like warning an exhibit of
fucking idiots looking at us the exact
way they should be looking at us.
Like, why would you stand in line for
two hours? It's a fucking hot dog.
He can buy packs of eight of them at
the grocery store, take them home,
grill 'em up and you know, you
don't even have to stay on hold.
What are you doing?
So this lady basically rolls down the
window and it's alternative comedian
looking fucking twat sticks her head
out the window and starts dripping with
sarcasm goes you guys
standing in line for hot dogs,
right? Just dripping with
sarcasm. There's nothing else.
There's nothing else on that corner that
we could be doing dripping with sarcasm
and the fucking democratic demographic
of shitheads that were in the line.
Do not hear the sarcasm and actually
answer her question like she was being
serious. This, this one guy's like, yeah.
So then she goes,
are they good?
Just dripping with sarcasm and this
other guy answers the question.
It suits the number one hot,
don't chew the country.
And at that point I just hung my
head in defeat going, you know what?
I fucking deserve this. I really want
to get mad at that girl in the car,
but I can't. I can't.
She's absolutely right.
She's actually trying to help us right
now to let us know how fucking stupid is
what we're doing. And I, I just,
I just hung my head and I stood in
fucking line and I swear to God,
I ended up getting up there and I'm
looking at the hot dogs and you know what?
I have forgotten.
They don't even toast the Bun.
They don't even us the fucking Bun. And
you just, they just stick it on there.
And if you have cheese, they just
sprinkle some cheese on it. You Chile,
they just put Chili on it and then you
go into the shack and there's no heat.
See is still cold
and you eat basically a ballpark frank.
And you stood in line for two hours and
you know, I'm one of these fucking guys,
man. It just, I swear to God,
you know that fool me once.
Shame on you fool me
twice. Shame on me. I,
you literally fool me like nine times
before I finally start picking up on it.
And now I finally I finally realized it.
Okay.
If you come out here to Los Angeles and,
and you know, and you ask people, Hey,
what do you do out here? And
somebody suggests to you,
oh, you got to go to pinks.
He got to go to pinks
and get a hot dog man.
And the best fucking hot dogs know they
say that Shit just slowly draw your
right. Well, I mean maybe it's going
to be a lefty, maybe a lefthand,
I dunno what drawback. Overhand
right. Overhand left. Right,
right into their mouth.
Don't even hit that notes.
Just put it right in the fucking mouth
because this is what I'm trying to say.
It's overrated. Okay. And those of
you who aren't new to my podcast,
I do underrated. Overrated. That is my
big overrated thing of the fucking week.
Alright.
Pink's hot dogs and La Sucks.
A big bag of fucking elk dick.
I've walked into fucking four star
restaurants and they've been like, oh,
how long is the wait,
Deanna has an agent know how long is the
way it's going to be? About 45 minutes.
And I always look at the person I'm with
and we'd go, you know what? Fuck that.
Fuck that. I'm not doing that.
I don't give a shit if, if,
if Mario Batali is cooking the meal,
I'm not standing here for 40 I'll
go get a slice. I don't give a shit.
And I stood in line for two hours for
God damn hot dog and got $145 a ticket.
Okay. All right, I got that up.
All right, that's it. You know,
that's been my week and I'm still
actually in a decent mood despite the fact
that my 11 and five patriots are
not in the playoffs. All my God,
what a week of sports and then
the Celtics loss to the Lakers,
which was actually a great game.
Hopefully foreshadowing
another great NBA finals.
But I gotta tell you something.
I don't think I've ever laughed harder
in my life than watching Pau Gasol,
whatever his fucking name
is that Kenny Loggins look,
Croatian Jackass fucking pump
hitting his fist off his chest.
Every time he hit a lay up, what the
fuck was he doing during that game?
I thought he's going to start
singing the theme of the titanic.
It's fucking running down
the court like Celine Dion.
Every time he hits the
shot. Oh, what the fuck?
But then he really thought he
proves something, didn't he? Yeah.
I guess you showed us,
you know,
you disappeared during the finals and
didn't get a championship ring, but Ooh,
watch out for Pau Gasol during a
regular season game in December.
You know that that's what's wrong
with sports. You know what I mean?
Act like you've been there.
Okay.
Act like you've been there and when you
fucking win a regular season game after
choking in the NBA finals,
don't fucking start pounding your chest.
You know when this 50 games left in
the season, what a fucking moron.
But I loved that he did it.
Him and that other guy with the,
with the hairdresser haircut, when he hit
that lay up and he just starts fucking
pounding his chest. Like he
said, Braveheart, you know,
like he just ran over a hill with blue
paint on his face and just defeated an
army twice the size of his dad.
A lay up,
get back on defense jackass.
I really hope that that pissed the
Celtics off. I know it did. I know it did.
And that's all. It's only going to help
us out. That fucking, who is that guy?
That guy with his hair cut.
They're talking about how oh you,
I don't even wear green on Christmas.
They totally j hate to show huge.
Oh yeah, I guess you showed
them, you know, green,
you know is also a part of nature.
It's a part of Christmas.
It doesn't have to mean Celtics,
but if you want to ruin your holiday
and wear blue man, um, but whatever
note, you know, my biggest thing is, uh,
I like, uh, what's his face there,
Andrew buying a man. That guy's the shit.
You know,
I didn't see any fucking chest pumping
from him and he could fucking put both of
those two other jackasses and fucking
snap 'em over his knee like a couple of
number two pencils and he wasn't
thumping his chest. He scared me.
He had a quiet confidence about him.
Those other guys look like a cop.
You know what they look like?
You ever see like when the spazz in
elementary school finally decides to fight
back,
you know,
you've been flicking them in the back
of the year for like three periods in a
row and he finally decides to
fight and you want to respect them,
but you can't cause he's making those
spazz noises as he throws punches, like,
and he's like half crying.
That's what those two jackasses look like.
Fucking pumping you goddamn fucking chest.
I really wish I could
remember the titanic song.
I'd fucking start singing it now,
even though I know I can't
sing as I proved a couple
of podcasts ago. All right,
let's get into the podcast here. Um,
the new year's resolutions. Okay.
Last week I talked about my new year's
resolution. If you new to my podcast,
my new year's resolution,
um,
for next year is I'm not going to
tip when I get bad service. Okay.
And, uh, at a, at a,
at a restaurant, I've,
I've been doing that religiously no
matter what the guilt that I always have,
I have to tip 20%,
no matter if you actually drop my piece
of cheesecake on the fucking floor,
you know, and spit on my
fork. I still give you 20,
20% and I'm not doing it anymore. All
right? If you suck, I'm not tipping you.
I can't just like not tip, but you know
mean you're not doing your fucking job.
You suck. All right? So that's
my new year's resolution.
If you give you give me bad
service, I'm not tipping. Um,
that's what I always hate to like in a,
like what's like celebrities?
Have you noticed that? Like in
like, um, and whatever, like, um,
like those, those, those celebrity blog
things or, or page six in New York,
there'll be a little goofy.
Ted Danson was at a diner and evidently
his finances aren't looking too good,
is he tip 4%.
You know,
at no point did they ever think
maybe that the service sucked.
Maybe asked for cheese and scrambled
eggs and they didn't give it to him.
And then he sent them back and then
they did what they did was took of cold
piece of cheese and just slapped it on
top and just gave it back to them that
way. And maybe he was a little bit
miffed and maybe that's why he didn't tip
immediately go, oh, he's famous and he
doesn't tip. He's a cheap fuck. You know,
cause I'm miserable with my own life. And,
um, so I'm going to tack the celebrity.
I don't know if ted Danson ever
got busted for not tipping,
but you know what the fuck I'm saying.
So anyways,
here's people's New Year's resolutions.
All right. Um, New Year's resolutions.
I want to make a conscious effort to
connect with the people around me because
human relationships are vital and I've
been too quick to take them for granted
or dismiss them all together.
When I stopped to think about what
of what I value most of my life,
it's all the memories,
good and bad with my friends and families.
That's what makes life worthwhile. You
know what? That was actually really nice,
but because of my choppy
out loud reading skills,
that's why I could never host the 700
club because that fucking big headed
jackass could have read that email with
his eyes closed through the last third
of it already getting ready to be
like, praise Jesus. Praise Jesus.
Let me see if I can do that.
Like the guy in the 700 club and this one
here comes from Chattanooga, Tennessee.
Praise God,
praise God for Chattanooga,
Tennessee and his new year's
resolution is this Lord.
I want to make the conscious effort to
connect with the people around me because
human relationships, our GSO
so vital to me and I, Lord,
I apologize,
I've been too quick to take them for
granted or to dimiss dismiss then fuck,
dismiss them altogether.
And when I stopped to think about
what I value most of my life, Jesus,
it's all the memories, good and bad. Even
when you challenged me, it's still good.
All the memories,
good and bad with my friends and family,
that's what makes my life worthwhile.
You know?
I think he made a very good point there,
I think a lot of times and laugh with you.
Forget things that are most vital and
everybody's talking about getting a new
guitar hero or the latest iPhone.
Those are just gadgets. People,
if you really think about it,
did Jesus have any gadgets? Ham?
He didn't even have any fucking shoes.
You didn't hear him bitching.
He was too busy putting
his hands on a leper. Okay,
so I want you all to put hands
on the TV screen right now.
Pray with me privately, just pregnancy
right now. Please lower Jesus Christ.
My Savior. Please help me to remember.
Lace shifts in my life are so,
so very vital.
Okay.
And how have a pot to piss in and even
though the bankers just still three cores,
if $1 trillion,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just happy because someday when I
die and I'm in the ground and the worms
are eating in my eye sockets,
I'm going to have a couple of wings and
I'm gonna be flying around in the class.
Praise Jesus.
And please seem your contributions
to the 700 club so I can get the,
the crow's feet taken off my face
cause I spent half the show squinting.
All right. I can read out
loud. I can read out loud.
I just have to get into praise Jesus. All
right. New Year's resolution number two.
Um,
number two,
I am going to stop dwelling on all the
garbage of the past and look forward to
the garbage of the future.
All right, that's uplifting.
Um, I really thought I was going
to get more new year's resolutions.
I guess people didn't wait. I have
one other one in that I thought I did.
Somebody saying that they weren't going
to do the hacky going to the gym thing,
that's the worst. Oh look
at me, I'm clicking, I'm
clicking on the computer again.
We did find out what the clicking
noise was. That was me doing that.
I'm going to stop doing
that because it bugs people.
Although somebody was so miserable,
told me to keep doing it because
he enjoys when I annoy people. Um,
last week I talked about going to the
movie milk and saying I really enjoyed it,
but I actually was avoiding the movie
because all my straight friends kept
saying it's a great movie, but I got warn
you, there's a lot of male kissing and,
and um, I was just talking
about how, you know,
that was something that was actually
pushing me away from that movie.
And I was like, does that make
me homophobic? I don't think so.
I just think,
you know,
I don't think it's anything wrong for
another man and another man to lock lips.
I personally just don't want to look at
it and I certainly don't want to pay $10
to see it. Um, so this guy says he's
this guy, I think put me straight here.
He said,
I understand that the sight of two men
kissing makes you slightly uncomfortable.
I feel the same way. The reason for
this is that you are heterosexual.
That being said,
I think you may be taking a bit far to
let it stand in your way of enjoying a
movie. Just because something
is uncomfortable to watch
doesn't mean it ruins the
movie. I find it marginally uncomfortable
to see someone get tortured,
but I'm not going to write off a whole
movie because of that and the porn
analogy. That's actually a
great point because yeah,
I would never want to get tortured,
but I've seen a bunch of movies where,
you know, guys get tortured and that type
of thing. But, uh, but you know something,
I can actually argue that point because,
you know,
when I watched lethal weapon and
I watched Mel Gibson, you know,
dislocated shoulder,
I know that it's not real.
He's not really dislocating
his is a shoulder.
But when you go to see milk,
um,
that guy's really kissing
that other guy really,
really kissing that other guy.
All right?
So, but I understand what he's saying.
He is right on a certain, I don't know,
but I dunno. I Dunno if this
is the whole fucking Oprah.
Let's turn guys into a puddle of Mush.
You think John Wayne would go see milk?
You know,
I'm not going to go see another
guy fucking another man say,
Oh God. That was a terrible impression.
All right, here's the second half of his,
uh, his analogy and the porn
analogy you made while hilarious,
was somewhat inaccurate.
Okay.
Gotta to be open to this criticism.
I'm not going to lose my temper. I'm,
he says when I watch
porn, I jack off. However,
I do not check off every time a man
and a woman kisses on screen during a
regular film. In fact, I
usually go boneless. God dammit.
That's a good point.
Likewise,
I imagined gay men jack off
while watching gay porn,
but not necessarily in the
middle of Brokeback mountain.
Um,
I'm going to argue with you on that one.
I bet.
I bet a lot of gay guys did jerk off
to that even though I didn't watch that
movie once again because I didn't
want to watch two guys fucking a 10th.
Um, and not even that, even if it was
a man and a woman fucking intense,
I wouldn't go see it because it's
basically a chick flick and I really don't
care about watching two people
make a relationship work.
Speaking of which,
if you guys seen that new movie coming
out with Leonardo Dicaprio and that fat
chick from the titanic,
that's so mean. Um,
that little full back with the
big head from, uh, the titanic.
I'm really being mean during
the holiday season. Um,
have you seen that? The
thing like I guess, you know,
they had two people with dreams and then
they moved out to the suburbs and then
they have a kid and then they just start
yelling at each other about how awful
their life sucks and they have all this
dramatic music and that's another movie
I'm not going to be able
to see because the entire,
I can't go see it in public because I'm
going to ruin it for the people around
me because the entire time I'm just
going to be yelling at the screen,
you know, why don't you
just move, sell your house,
go back to the city. It's free
country. You're able to do that. Hello?
I mean I'm, what am I going to watch? 90
minutes of them yelling at each other.
I even want Tupperware honey.
Okay.
He wanted an Ottoman,
not me who wanted it
and him fucking punching a
cupboard right near her head.
And I just, you know, move,
get divorced. You know, I,
I've really learned that about anger is,
is that's when a lot of anger is when
you feel powerless in the situation and
you're not powerless.
You have the intelligence to make the
decision to get out of a bad. I mean,
I know it's not that easy, but
you know, but anyways, you know,
I want to commend that guy
who sent in all that stuff.
He really made some great
points. Um, you know,
I think you made some good
points, but like, uh, yeah,
there's a big part of me while I still
feel like I'm right. I mean, I don't know.
Do, do I want to get comfortable
watching two guys make out? We'll go,
let's see. What am I afraid of? The
obvious. Then I'm going to watch Santa.
It's going to turn me gay. Stupid.
All right. You know what Mike Flynn,
you're fucking right. Okay. You're right.
You're God that you're absolutely right.
And, uh, you said Ts. Fuck the Bruins.
Well, you can say that all you want, dude.
They're like fucking 27, five. All right.
Which what's your team exactly? Let
me, you sit there and deal with that.
All right. Um, what do we got next?
Movie reviews. Movie reviews.
No, I did this last week.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
This is why you always say the clicking
sound because I'm not organized.
Okay, here we go.
Underrated. Overrated. Okay.
I think you guys know not to go to
pink's hot dogs at Labrea and Melrose.
Do not go there and feel free to make
fun of the people who stand in line at
pink's hot dogs because evidently we
don't understand sarcasm so you know,
do anything you want.
Stick your head out the window and just
be as sarcastic as you want and they
will just answer your questions.
You know what?
That's the big thing that we should
just drive by and heckle the people at
Pink's hot dogs.
I think I'm going to do that next time,
which is very hypocritical
because I stood in line last week.
I want to go down there and protest them.
Just have a sign and just be like,
you know it's,
they're not that good or it's not worth
it or maybe I'll just yell out obvious
shit just to hear people answer it,
aren't you called?
Yeah. As a matter of
fact, I am. I'm all right.
Overrated. If we go over rated. This
person says this week overrated.
Owen Wilson over 1 billion
in box office. But, but the,
but Jesus Christ, I can't read
out loud. This is actually funny.
Let me go back to the beginning to
restart the comedy momentum. Okay.
Overrated.
Owen Wilson over 1 billion in box office,
but does this douchebag
really make anyone laugh?
This guy makes cute movies like
wedding crashers and Rushmore.
Both cute but not funny.
I will never bust a gut laughing
watching this crooked nose. No talent.
And why do they always pucker
his lips in every promo shot?
I'll leave that to your imagination.
Wow.
He's going after Owen Wilson didn't that
guy just tried to kill himself a few
months ago. You know, I think he tried
to kill himself because he keeps making,
yeah, he makes these cute little movies.
Remember that you, me and dupree,
I mean that the, the, the fucking
title of that movie alone, you know,
it's going to suck. And you know, he's uh,
and he's got another one of those.
I'm going out another one.
Those kind of movies. You mean to
pre meet you and Magoo? He just,
he just know they're going to suck.
You're going to Improv and the crew's
going to be laughing cause they're afraid
not to laugh because you're famous after
each take. I think pockets his lip.
So maybe you don't look at his nose.
I think that that's what he does.
Or maybe he's like coming to the
realization that he's actually in a movie
called you,
me and dupree.
It rines that'll get them. You
know what? I Bet I, you know,
I don't even know how to
look up box office numbers.
I bet. I bet it did. Great.
You know I, this is, I know what I think,
why I like guys like that ended up killing
themselves because I think you very
subtly get taken off track
in this business and you've,
you forget who you are and why you
ever even gotten this business.
And I actually had that feeling last
night when I was watching one of those
cooking shows.
I basically watched football all day,
watch my patriots do the what they had
to do and then I watched the fucking
fumbling,
bumbling stumbling jets
kill my fucking post season.
Um, so yeah, I watched
eight hours of football,
so at that point it my girls,
so like okay, it's my turn.
So she puts on the cooking network and
I'm watching one of those iron chef
shows, some sort of throw down, I
don't know what the fuck it was,
but I'm watching Bobby flay and a,
you know,
pretty famous Goddamn chef with his
own TV show already and all his own
restaurants and he's standing there
getting judged by these jackasses.
Just regular people going, you
know, I thought the falafel,
the outside was a little too greasy while
the inside was a little too flaky and
I'm just sitting there looking at the
expression on his face and he really,
it really comes one of those moments like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I don't need to do this.
Why did I get into this business I got
in this business because I love to cook.
I like to cook. I like
to make people, you know,
make a little money off the
shit and make people happy.
Just eat my food and shut the
fuck up. Why am I, what am I,
why am I standing here is
just construction worker is
his fucking critiquing my
falafel. You know what it was? It was uh,
John Starks from the Knicks.
We was critique and
actually he liked his full,
I don't know who the fuck
wants some Queen Latifa.
I don't know what the fuck it was,
but 80 influence deals like, dude,
you didn't have to go through this
fucking humiliation. You already made it,
you know, and you're standing
here on TV and that they're,
they're filming your fucking humiliation.
And I think that that's what
happens to guys like Owen Wilson.
He got into this business.
No one gets in this business to be in me,
you and dupree you want
to make on the waterfront.
You want to be in the next
Godfather, whatever you want.
You want to do that shit.
But what happens? You've got a mortgage
payment, he got shit you have to do,
you know, all your relatives and
third cousins know you're famous.
So the very least she got to buy them
all iPods to Christmas. That costs money.
And next thing you know you're you and me,
you and Magoo.
And that's still the only
book he can have on your face.
Sort of put puckering up your
lips. Like it's not like, you know,
do you want to kiss me? And so like, Ooh,
Ooh I guess this one's going to suck.
Sorry about this one guys. I swear to God,
the next one's going to be a
little more artistic, you know,
and then you look,
somebody asked for an hour and a half
and somehow that ends up in the paper and
they call you the butterscotch stallion.
And the next thing you know, I dunno,
I don't fucking know.
I don't even know what,
I don't even know what any of
that even meant. But uh, yeah,
I wouldn't say that that guy's overrated.
I think you know, he's a actually he is,
cause it's, we'll just keep making
money. I think he's a good actor,
but he doesn't make good
movies. All right. Underrated.
Um, this guy says the movie,
the last dragon. Anything with two
lead characters, names Sho Nuff,
the Shogun of Harlem.
And Bruce Leroy has my attempt,
my ads or admiration. Once again, I
butcher what the fucking guy wrote.
I mean,
you know what?
You guys are going to have to start
getting like leaving me voicemail messages
and then I'll just press play cause I
can not read out loud to save my life.
All right, overrated. Um,
find my space bitches sending you
invites to join them at clubs,
record release parties or New Year's
events. I'm not really going to meet them.
And what am I going to say if I
do meet him? Well good and boy,
you from my mind space. DANCO
mango would you? Exactly.
You might as well go stand in line for
a fucking hot dog at pinks. You don't.
Half the time it's not even,
it's not even the person you know,
it's usually some fucking fat bald guy
who just takes some random picture of a
girl with a bikini, you know? All
right. Here's another underrated guy.
I liked this one. Somebody said,
Billy squire is underrated.
It gets no Cli. His music gets no
classic rock radio play anymore.
But tell me that, don't
say no. Doesn't kick ass.
Uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno about Billy Squire squire.
He's kind of like drew Bledsoe.
You know, he sorta has hall
of fame numbers, but he
never, he never won a ring,
you know, I dunno. Let's see. Let's see.
Is he further defense and let's
see what else he has to say.
Said admittedly it's not as in the
same league as back in black. Yes,
exactly.
But when lonely in the night or the
stroke or my kind of lover unexpectedly do
get radio airplay,
you blast the car stereo.
All right. I gotta tell you
something. When the stroke comes on,
I actually turn it down a little bit.
I'd have to be in the middle of the
Berkshires somewhere in the middle of
nowhere to actually turn that
song. It's just, I dunno,
that song. Uh, I think if
you're in seventh grade,
that song holds up,
you know,
and the added that day had you heard
stroke mi stroke me. I mean
he guys, he's a rock star.
He really still just getting hand
jobs and I don't get it. Um, I bought,
I got to say the drummer in Billy
Scwarz band did the best John Bonham
impersonation I ever heard.
And I actually looked him
up one time on the Internet.
I found out that he actually
passed away. So, uh,
rest in peace drummer from Billy squire.
Alright,
here's this, you know, hopefully
isn't that nice during the holidays.
All right bill. No. What's really
underrated? I like this one. How do she,
someone comes off when they say
they liked the foreign film.
All right,
here's his story.
This guy I work with who likes to try
and sound cultured cause he sees these,
these uh,
these independent Philly's foreign movies
that won best picture at the Albanian
film festival or some shit like that.
And everyone he talks and
every time he talks up a movie,
it just sounds like a moving,
only a douche bag would enjoy.
But what makes it worse
is what he'll totally is.
That'll totally dismiss any movie
that sounds that anyone else likes.
I recently saw the wrestler with Mickey
work and I was telling someone at work
that it was,
it was pretty good.
And right away there's
deuce chimes in going.
You went to see you movie about wrestling.
This comment from a guy who watched the
three hour movie about some old man who
likes to make pottery and he had to
read the whole thing because it was,
the dialogue was in Turkish by the way.
Go see wrestling.
You don't have to like wrestling to
appreciate the story. Exactly. Um,
all right. First of all, just because
it's a foreign film and you have to,
you know,
read subtitles doesn't mean it's sucks,
but that also doesn't
mean that it's great.
And just because of movies about wrestling
doesn't mean it's sucks because this
guy is absolutely right.
I saw the wrestler to fuck.
I think it's a really good
movie. And Mickey workers.
Great. And um, I don't know.
Go see it back. Come
on. It's making Brooke.
What do you get the guy put on
40 pounds of muscle? Wink, wink.
You know anybody else out there? Work out.
How much protein do you have to ingest?
Wink, wink to put on 40 pounds
of muscle. But then again,
those wrestlers put on 40 pounds of muscle
muscle. Wink, wink. So he did the same.
He was method acting.
He did what he had to do to point
of 40 pounds of muscle and a,
he looked pretty good and the
tights, they're all right. Uh,
here's a questions or the weekend then
I'm going to wrap up this podcast just
because,
um,
I listened to last week's podcast as I
was fixing some things on my page and I
thought it went a long way too long.
I think somewhere around a half hours.
A good amount of time. All right.
[inaudible] question number one.
So as a,
a former member of planet fitness and
having a moral obligation a few weeks ago,
I had no choice but to quit. Plan is, uh,
what am I doing here is just overrated.
Underrated.
See, I, I just, I'm just
disorganized. All right.
I started reading. It's, and I
have to read it. What is this?
Planet fitness disappoints me on several
levels. First off, all their franchises,
brand branches, paint. Most if not
all the floor equipment. Uh, gay,
purple and yellow color.
Oh,
this is a guy trying to say
that all gyms are gay now.
And I'm, is there a question
at the end of this all. Okay.
What ever happened to
real gyms? Okay. Yeah.
The equipment is painted a gay
purple and yellow color. Yeah,
just like the Lakers.
Oh to comfort sensitive people that
are intimidated by muscle heads and or
fitness clubs or reality in general.
And that is gay.
I think by gay he means stupid.
And what is even more gay is the fact
that you're not allowed to have a barbell
on the floor.
That means no dead lifts.
Free standing squats and separate that.
Doesn't that mean don't
leave the barbell there?
Cause they don't want to be sued?
I Dunno.
And it's not like when
others I work out with,
we are intentionally trying
to intimidate people.
We're not acting like how Cogan did back
in the day to excite a crowd before a
match. I'm five eight, 160
pounds of scared white meat.
I had to quit because I don't want to
be converted anymore into a pussy by
conforming to their lame rules.
I didn't know what the fuck.
You know what half of this is my
me not being able to read out loud
as corporate America is comforting.
Most Mormons in this country,
they are also eradicating conventional
wisdom in American culture to increase
their revenue regardless of repercussion.
La Fitness sucks balls to at GC,
I dunno what,
what am I having to the real
gyms? There's this question, ah,
there are real gyms and you go there
and you lay on the floor to do a fucking
set ups in the next day you have some
sort of rash like you're on the ultimate
fighter and then they have to, they
don't mop down there fucking mats enough.
I'm number two. I'm sorry I butchered
that whole thing. I apologize.
I'll send you a refrigerator magnet
or something. All right. Bill,
you occasionally mention
having a girlfriend and you
recently went on a hockey
trip. Uh, yeah, I did. I
went on three day trip.
I went to a home game
of the Calgary flames,
Edmonton Oilers and the Vancouver
Canucks. He, she, he goes,
I assume she did not go along.
What kind of obstacles did you
have to hurdle to avoid a hearing?
A bunch of stupid girl
complaints about that trip.
I didn't have to hurdle any of them.
I have a great relationship because I
fought the battles I needed to fight so
that when I say I'm going on a
hockey trip, they can't be like,
oh,
you don't care about me.
No, that's not what it means.
Is that what it means at all?
It means I like hockey and I want to
go on a trip. That's all it means.
See on Monday, yeah, no.
Earlier in my, my dating career,
I used to have to go through shit
like that. But you know, you just,
you just have to have the
battles and you don't get,
don't scream and yell if you just
say in a very nice way. Listen,
I worked very hard this
year. You know, I've, I've,
uh, you know, done.
I'm not going to get it until the intimate
details of shit that I've done. Okay.
I've earned the right.
Okay. I'm coming back.
I'm not going to go up there and fucking
bang an Eskimo. I'm just going up there,
you know, with some friends to go on a
hockey trip, there's no problems. Okay.
Stop making me feel guilty
for doing something fun
and uh, that pretty much
ends it. In other words,
grow a Dick and your fucking relationship
and a, yeah, don't, don't paint yourself.
If you're in a relationship right
now where you're not allowed to go do
something fun with somebody other
than the person you're dating,
you're not in a relationship,
you are actually a hostage.
And you need to get out of that situation.
You know, make a youtube video, blink,
SOS,
do whatever the fuck you have to do,
but get out of that relationship because
just get out of it because it's not
going to get better once you've given
up that territory. You know what I mean?
It's like all these Mexicans you
see protesting about, you know,
getting Texas back. You're not getting
it back. You're not. It's over.
It's fucking done. You know, you
need to pick up a gun to get it back.
So put down your signs cause it's fucking
over. All right. Question number three.
Uh, Bill podcast. Quite
a fuck ass was okay.
One of my favorite things to do every
month is flipped a flipped to the back of
vanity fair to see if an artist,
I like his answer,
answering the Proust questionnaire.
Um,
whatever the fuck that is.
There are. Okay. Basically,
there are a slew of questions and I would
love to hear how you would answer all
of them. But for the purpose of this
email, I will only specifically ask,
what are your favorite favorite qualities
in a man and what are your favorite
qualities in a woman? Oh, okay. So this
is obviously a questionnaire where they,
they asked celebrities what
they're looking for in a mate.
What are my favorite qualities in a man?
Um,
he's not a Douche.
Uh,
he adheres to Guy Code,
which I'm not going to tell you what
that is because only men should know what
that is.
Um,
has a strong jaw orders for
me when I go out to dinner,
holds the door, act like a gentleman,
but isn't afraid of my opinions.
Um, yeah, I dunno.
What are my favorite qualities
in a man? Uh, I don't know.
He eats with his mouth closed,
you know,
I don't like those fucking a crow,
like fucking half a caveman guys.
You know what I mean? Like those
guys, like, uh, like more on,
I don't like hanging around with
dumb people, men or women and uh,
yeah, I, you know,
I like to be hanging out with a guy who's
in a relationship that he's happy to
be in,
so I don't have to listen to them bitch
about it or pretend to be happy in it.
Common sense stuff. And one of my
favorite qualities in a woman. Um,
I like a woman who's,
who's a neat one of my biggest
turnoff of women's are a women's,
I don't know, I don't like about the
women's is when the pitch is be messy. No,
seriously, a woman who is messy is
one of the biggest turnoffs ever.
You know what I mean? That's like a
guy who can't pick up something heavy.
You know, if you're like a
woman, you know, like, oh,
can you give me a hand with this?
And he like breaks a nail.
Like when that turn you off, that's
like ground zero of being a man as you,
you should actually have some sort of
physical strength and what the woman is,
they should know how to keep
the house clean. That's right.
I just said that and I don't
think that is sexist. All right.
I think that's one of the fucking
great things that a woman does,
teaches you how not to
live like a fucking animal.
It's one of the things that they're
allegedly naturally good at,
although I find a lot of women to
be pretty fucking messy. And, um,
yeah,
I'm old school women who can cook
and clean and all that type of stuff,
you know? Um, I'm not saying
that I'm going to walk,
walk in like a caveman with mud on my
shoes and you should have to sweep up
behind me,
but like the same way women still want
guys to know how to be handy around the
house. Yeah. Women who
can cook or the Shit,
women with a sense of humor woman who
actually are into sports a little bit.
I understand. Most of you
think it's retarded. Yeah.
That type of Shit, you know,
and uh, I don't like
horse. I like classy women.
Women who are, uh, yeah, classically
beautiful. Yeah. I Dunno.
That type of shit and you know, it's
none of your fucking business. All right.
After that was,
I just felt bad divulging all
that personally information
and I just felt like I
was opening up too much and
I got a little scared. Okay.
The very least in this podcast question,
you know,
you've got to listening to them and my
impression of the 700 club. All right,
question number four. Um, do
you believe in God? If so,
how can you be so fucking
stupid? Um, you know,
I actually understand
what you're saying that,
but I definitely do
believe in a higher power,
but I don't believe in it within
the context of organized religion.
Um, if that makes any sense. I definitely
believe in a higher power something,
whatever it is.
Like how the fuck did
all this stuff get made?
But it's just so crazy to think that
there's this, this big thing that,
that made all of it.
And where was he when he made it or it
didn't he have to be in something that
had to be created.
I don't know what the fuck's going on,
but I know the answers are
not in organized religion.
That is just basically
an updated version of,
of cavemen paintings on the
walls. And, uh, you know,
when people get really religious,
super, super religious,
they somehow get really angry and they
get violent and it leads to wars. And,
uh, yeah, I don't believe in
it, but I definitely, you know,
when I contemplate my own death,
I do get scared that I'm not a member
of any organized religion, you know,
so, uh, I dunno. I Dunno, you know,
I don't fucking know. I believe in a
higher power, but I don't believe it.
And it within organized religion.
Okay. The final question.
Here we go. Number five,
Bill, is there any way to listen to
the uninformed show you do on Xm?
I don't have an annex XM subscription,
but I did enjoy the live version you
did on opiate Anthony a couple of weeks
back while the one we did on opie
and Anthony was on Xm, wasn't it?
Um,
no,
there's no way to listen to it without
that and we don't have the money in the
budget to, uh, I don't,
I don't know what we have to do with that.
That's something that's one of my New
Year's resolutions to somehow get it up on
the Internet.
For those of you new to the podcast,
I do this radio show uninformed.
It's on Xm. I do it with Joe to Rosa.
We do a once a month or lately,
once every other month because shit
has been fucking weird. But anyways,
that is the end of the podcast.
Um,
I appreciate you guys a all this year,
you know,
I just want to say thanks to everybody
for everybody's sending in your questions
and uh, you know your
contributions to the podcast.
So the reasons why that it's now 50
minutes long as opposed to the back of the
day.
Remember back in the day when I used to
do it in a one room shack and I can only
talk for eight minutes and then I'd
have to hang up. Well thanks to you,
it works for all of us. The bill burn
Monday morning podcast. All right,
you guys have a very happy new year
and um, oh there's one for you.
That's what I think is fucking
overrated is new years. It's,
it's,
it's the dumbest fucking thing ever.
I'm actually going to walk out and make
a peanut butter sandwich while I talk
about how overrated fucking new year's
this and this. This is bonus time.
You guys don't have to listen to this.
This is like after the
game when you know who won
and you're listening to the postgame
analysis and there's really no reason to
fucking do that.
This is what this part of the podcast
is seen on obligated to listen to any of
that as I make a fucking peanut
butter sandwich. MMM. Look at that.
There's the parking tickets from
a tank sweat on my refrigerator,
just mocking me,
mocking me and the awful fucking
hot dog that I got. Yeah,
you don't need to go out on new
years. You know, I've actually been,
cause I'm finally taking new years off.
I'm looking at all these regular bars,
you know, of course my girl
wants to go someplace fancy,
so she has a place to where her new
year's stress, which I totally understand.
Banalities regular bars that have
like a fucking $10 cover charge.
It's all 40 bucks.
50 75 someplaces are leaving
even like 150 bucks to do what?
Go out and drink,
which you can do at home for free.
And now he's standing next to fucking,
now it's jam packed. It's hot.
People with plastic hats. Those stupid
fucking horns blowing in your ear.
That's how you really want
to bring in the new year,
getting completely overcharged for some
shit to stand with a bunch of other
douche bags.
That's all overrated and all you fucking
scared whores out there whose dads
didn't stick around.
So you have low self esteem and your
drink too much and then you go into that
panic way like, oh my God, I, it's
new years. I need someone to kiss.
I have to have someone to kiss. You
don't, don't give into peer pressure.
You know sweetheart,
if you want to wonder why you always
ended up in the bathroom on your knees and
the stall, it's because you given to herd
mentality. You don't have to do that.
You don't, you don't need somebody to
kiss, but you need to do is contemplate,
you know,
the fact that you don't have someone to
kiss and that that's okay and that you
should hold out for somebody who's going
to treat you good rather than drag you
in at,
into the fucking bathroom at 1201
can make you fucking, you know,
she can suck your first deck
of 2000 Oh nine you know,
2000 oh nine 2009 you know what I mean?
You know,
I dunno,
you don't actually put jelly on it.
I've been trying to just do the protein,
but I had to put jelly on a
sandwich because you know,
you try to eat a peanut
butter sandwich and you know,
you dislocate your job
by the time get done,
she went off and it's just a
fucking pain in the ass. So anyways,
thanks for listening to
the podcast everybody.
Please keep the questions coming in and
it's not too late to send in your New
Year's resolutions. And
you know what? I liked it.
A lot of people didn't send
any new year's resolutions.
You didn't follow the
fucking pack and make one.
You could make one anytime of
the year and uh, that's it.
I'm in my little breasts, breakfast
Nook, and the sun is shining it.
Then I feel special.